hi I'm prison family I'm Tracy McMillan
relationship expert author and creator
of the show unprisoned on Hulu and you
guys have been sharing so many
interesting thoughts and feelings about
the show and I wanted to respond to some
of them so here we go Jasmine says while
my dad wasn't in jail he was still
absent from my life and my first meeting
was at a block party so I can relate to
the awkwardness of meeting and getting
to know a stranger I think the the idea
that you're supposed to be close to them
is what causes a whole bunch of the
tension so for me it was always just
about letting the relationship be
exactly where it is if it felt awkward I
let it feel awkward so Destiny writes I
am watching episode 6 of unprisoned
directed by Miss pneuma and I am crying
my mom didn't go to prison but we've had
a complicated relationship and this
episode has helped me to have more
empathy for things she's been through
that I have no idea about episode 6 is
taken directly from my own life my dad
my son and I all went to his family home
in Midway Alabama a town of 400 people
and went to the house abandoned that he
was born in and the story of my
grandmother being dragged out in the
middle of the night all that is true so
many people individuals have been
through traumas and then those get
passed down through families we can be
the the beginning of the healing we can
be the beginning of the change yeah I
think I'm starting to see that
okay so Noemi writes unprisoned Hulu is
truly a master class of great
storytelling it unapologetically Dives
deep into the uncomfortable phases of
life yet does it in such a way where you
don't feel heavy watching rather you
feel light comforted and encouraged
wow that is such a cool and nice thing
to say yeah I just wrote From The Heart
and every person involved in this show
is committed to this notion of being in
their highest self I feel like that is
the thing that ultimately makes the show
what it is is all these individuals
coming together for this kind of bigger
purpose and it's been really special
foreign
[Music]